foreign
[Music]
main story in just a moment that missile
strike that's hit Poland first what's
happening with the inflation figures
Paul's standing by for us this morning
Paul tell us
inflation has leapt by a full percentage
point in October the latest figures came
from the office for National statistics
show that inflation is running at 11.1
that is clearly the highest figure in 40
years it's up from 10.1 percent as the
figure was running September it reflects
the impact of the increase in domestic
energy prices particularly you'll recall
we had a price cap as it was admitted to
buy off German just under 2 000 pounds
that Rose to the average bill not the
maximum of around two and a half
thousand pounds in October with
government energy support trying to keep
that number down the cost of bills down
but it hasn't stopped inflation rising
to 11.1 percent we may be nearing the
peak of inflation with this figure the
bank of England initially thought it
would go as high as 13 but government
energy support may keep the lid on it a
little and this could be the top of the
inflation Peak but there's still an
enormous amount of price Rises running
through the economy food inflation the
other major contributing factor the
impact of this number one right through
the economy it'll affect all sorts of
decisions not least what the bank of
England decides to do next with interest
rates up to three percent already could
they go higher yet as the bank tries to
make sure that this is the top of the
inflation curve but to repeat the number
11.1 percent way ahead of Economist
expectations and a very real
confirmation of what consumers and
businesses already know prices are
rising and it hurts
um is this already baked in to the
Autumn statement that we're expecting
from the chancellor tomorrow do you
think Paul
it's certainly been one of the driving
uh the driving influences on the way
Jeremy Hunter Rishi sunak have
approached the Autumn statement Jeremy
Hunt told our colleague Sophie Ridge on
Sunday that the best thing he could do
was help the bank of England tackle
inflation so there's certainly it's one
of the key influences this inflationary
environment is that the biggest
challenge the economy faces and what
both the the treasury and Mr Hunt and
certainly the bank of England are trying
to do is to ensure that inflation Falls
away as quickly as possible and as
little of the impact is embedded in the
jargon much of this information driven
by Energy prices we know they have risen
exacerbated largely by the war in
Ukraine and the impact on Russian energy
Supply and costs Rising around the world
wherever we get our energy from the aim
is to try and show that when that passes
it hasn't become embedded in our economy
through for example wage Rises that
can't be sustained we heard yesterday
that real in real terms because of the
pressure of inflation wages are in fact
in real terms Falling by more than three
percent even though they've been going
up on average six percent the real pound
in your pocket is simply worth less of
course the pain on a consumer and
household budgets is only just starting
on Thursday we're going to hear about
the tax Rises that the chancellor
believes we need to impose to give the
UK back its economic credibility so this
is a an economic challenge with many
many facets but inflation the chief one
at 11.1 percent the highest number in 40
years and much higher than was expected
by the general consensus in the market
well this is a terrifying figure for our
viewers waking up to us this morning
11.1 you've talked about the the impact
that it will have on the on the budget
but on the daily budget for people who
are literally trying to make ends meet
what might it mean for mortgages
we have seen mortgages increase since
the real Spike the the the the trigger
for the sharp increase in mortgages came
uh what feels like a very long time ago
now September the 23rd when kwaziquating
uh implemented Liz truss's growth plan
you'll recall that um uh it's initial
its immediate impact was to cause loss
of confidence in the UK the cost of
borrowing investors wanted more return
to lend the UK money the cost of
borrowing roads and that had an
immediate push through into the mortgage
Market mortgage uh fixed rates for two
and five-year mortgages above six
percent where they have remained that is
unlikely there certainly isn't going to
help them drop back quickly very
interesting the bank of England was
talking about this when it increased
interest rates by 0.75 percentage points
uh earlier this month it said it didn't
believe mortgage rates would have to go
as high as the market was saying that
interest rates rather wouldn't have to
go as high as the market thought they
the market was expecting rates to rise
to around five percent that base rate of
course informs mortgage rates one
wonders quite what the bank will make of
this inflation jump beyond their
expectations they raise interest and
increase interest rates of course to try
and dampen demand in the economy and
bring inflation down will this higher
figure mean that interest rates have to
rise further perhaps than even the bank
was expecting just a couple of weeks ago
if they do then mortgage rates will
likely have to Trend higher too so if
you are in the middle of trying to buy a
home or sell a home this is not going to
help and none of it is going to help
with consumer confidence as we approach
Christmas when uh certainly the Econo
will be hoping to benefit from us all
opening our wallets and digging a little
deeper we'll have to see how this
affects real-term spending I know you're
going to Crunch into these numbers for
me Paul aren't you and you'll be back
with us very shortly with more
information for now thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot my goodness me look
at that UK inflation above 11 for the
first time in 40 years 11.1 percent to
be precise I'm really sorry to have to
bring you that news this morning don't
forget of course that we have got the
Chancellor's Autumn statement uh
tomorrow lunchtime has he already baked
those figures in what's going to happen
next to your household budget
terrible news isn't it sorry about that
um also want to update you on what's
Happening uh with events in Poland and
the deaths of two people uh on the
border with Ukraine after a missile hit
a small village U.S officials now
suggesting the missile was fired by
Ukraine as it forces attempt to
intercept an incoming Russian missile it
came at a time when G20 leaders were
gathered for talks in Indonesia with the
war in Ukraine top of the agenda
report on that in just a moment but I
just want to bring you the latest that
we're hearing uh from Medvedev um in
Russia he's uh quoted by the Reuters
news agency within the last few moments
saying that the Polish incident shows
that the West's hybrid Warfare raises
the prospect of Another World War
Cordelia has more for us in Bali
a small village and a blast that sent
shockwaves around the world initial
reports suggested Russia may have fired
it at Poland a NATO member killing two
peoples in Bali fresh from an emergency
meeting Rishi sunak and Joe Biden
discuss the attack but going into it the
American president sounded uncertain
it now appears the missile that hit
Poland was fired by Ukrainian forces
that's an incoming Russian missile that
has not yet been confirmed
but this is what it looked like close up
farm machinery damaged the landscard
sir a Russia firing weapons into a NATO
member put the world on high alert but
the Diplomatic show went on a mangrove
planting just as seeds of Doubt were
sown across the G20 about the
unpredictable absentee Vladimir Putin
Russia denied any involvement saying in
a statement it had launched no strikes
in the area and that the reports were a
deliberate propagation
what world leaders are now focusing on
are the missiles they say they know
Russia did fire 100 in Ukraine yesterday
alone
hitting missiles on NATO territory this
is a Russian missile attack on
collective security this is a very
significant escalation we must act
this was a moment of Jeopardy and things
are still unclear in a deeply Mercurial
era Clarity and calm heads will be
crucial
well Cordelia joining us as indeed is
Adam Cordelia to you uh first of all
um what are the diplomats what are the
politicians saying this morning
well okay good morning to you I think we
have seen here the diplomats are
throwing caution and doubt as those
initial reports came out focusing not on
the allegation that this was a Russian
missile striking Poland and instead
focusing on the missiles they know to
have hit Ukraine I think they want to
build a consensus here to make clear
they want to end what so many including
Rishi sunak have described as a barbaric
war and Richie sunac today yet again
reiterating that sentiment take a listen
Ethan Ukraine is having to use missiles
as the defend its Homeland it's having
to defend its Homeland against an
illegal and barbaric set of strikes by
Russia and said over 80 yesterday at the
same time that we were sitting together
gathered as the G20 calling for peace I
think Russia displayed absolute contempt
for the International System by raining
down so many missiles on civilian
targets
prime minister taking a tough stance on
Russia there just to add K he was due to
meet the Chinese leader Xi Jinping today
that meeting has been canceled okay
thanks um for now Cordelia let's bring
in Adam should we Adam we're hearing
from the Russians within the last few
minutes saying you know we could be
facing Another World War
um Poland is a NATO country what happens
now
Ito today in just under a couple of
hours time there will be a meeting of
ambassadors each country has its
ambassador to Nato this happens weekly
anyway but it will discuss their uh
response to this situation now I think
that there's worth saying there's lots
of moving Parts here Poland is a NATO
member Poland has in recent times become
vehement that there needs a stronger
response against Russia prime minister
moraviki has talked about uh bringing
more weapon systems into Europe and to
doing more to support Ukraine so there
are those who think that Poland has to
an extent been spoiling for a fight here
so last night there were plenty around
Europe and within NATO who were
immediately calling for calm and saying
we need to know exactly what has
happened clearly though there will be a
response of some kind and that is going
to be talked about today and and two
expressions you're going to hear a lot
of are Article 4
and article 5. these are two bits of the
NATO Charter so let's have a look at
what they mean and what happens when you
uh you invoke them if we start first of
all with article four what that says and
this is the one that is most likely I
think to be invoked there it goes that
says the parties will consult together
whenever in the opinion of any of them
the territorial Integrity political
Independence or security of any of the
parties is threatened I will put that
into English in a moment Article 5 is a
more combustible is a more front foot
response and it says the parties agree
that an armed attack against one or more
of them in Europe or North America shall
be considered an attack against them all
and consequently they agree uh that if
such an attack armed attack occurs each
of them an exercise of the right of
individual or Collective self-defense
right how do we put that into English
number two the second one you heard
Article 5 means that if a NATO nation is
attacked then the rest of the
organization considers that to be an
attack on one country being an attack on
all of them in other words that NATO
must respond together to this armed
attack on NATO territory that has only
been invoked once and that was after 9
11 when other NATO Nations sent planes
to patrol the sky around the United
States Article 4 first one that I read
out to effectively means I want to call
a meeting I want to call an emergency
meeting to discuss this event that is a
much lower level response they're going
to be a meeting today at NATO anyway I
think that is the one that is more
likely to happen it's already happened
once this year anyway when Russia
invaded Ukraine I think Poland will ask
for that and I think it is very likely
to get it one final thought is that even
if this does turn out to have been not a
deliberate attack an argument will be
made that if Russia continues to rain
missiles done in Ukraine further events
like this are inevitable and that
something has to be done okay um thank
you both
um for now
um so many stories developing as we've
come on air this morning but let's just
go to Alex Rossi should we who is
standing by for us in uh Ukraine this
morning I'm just looking at the wise
Services I'm chatting
um to you Alex and suggestions
um developing from the former Russian uh
president Dimitri Medvedev talking about
incident uh the missile strike of course
which uh takes the West uh closer to
another world war what's the view where
you are this morning good morning to you
well the dangers of this war have been
apparent for a very long time
miscalculation or accident could of
course trigger a conflagration much
bigger than the one that's going on
within Ukraine the response from the
ukrainians at the moment is that they
are saying they're not sure exactly uh
what happens we're told by the Air
Commands spokesperson the Air Defense
command spokesperson that they did uh
strike out at 15 Russian missiles in the
west of the country in the direction of
Poland and they are calling for an
urgent investigation but certainly this
just underlines how easy it would be for
this conflict here to spiral out of
control I think the other thing that's
worth bearing in mind uh as well of
course is what the strategy is of the
Russians Behind these attacks around 100
missiles striking cities across Ukraine
where we are in mikalayev we actually
saw or one of those cruise missiles
flying with a deadly wine above our
heads not very high keeping low so it
could evade the air defense systems the
ukrainians we didn't hear a landing here
or an explosion here we think it was on
its way to Odessa but clearly there is a
strategy by the Russians to try to bring
the Ukrainian people to their knees you
could see the rubble behind me this is a
a previous strike here this is a hotel
where we're staying that was hit the
Russians are hitting residential
buildings but they're key Target at the
moment seems to be civilian
infrastructure the water is off where we
are it's off in many places around the
country the electricity is sporadic or
out in many places and I think it's it's
clearly a strategy by the Russians to
try to bring the civilian population to
their knees history tells us though that
it's very unlikely to work but these
attacks I think that the feeling here is
that these uh attacks are likely to
continue
okay thank you thanks very much also
joining us this morning is Robert the
senior fellow at the Casimir Pulaski
foundation in uh Poland hello to you sir
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning your reaction to the news
that's been developing overnight
good morning well let me clarify one
thing it's it's it's not the polls that
becoming demos suggested I mean you know
there's been various reports uh you know
some of them contradictory the truth is
that we we have a war ongoing Europe and
that's the war which is waged by Russia
against Ukraine and you know this
missile attacks barbaric against you
know civilian targets that have been
happening before uh so uh whether it is
the actual Russian missile uh the Polish
foreign Ministry it was someone the
Russian Ambassador quite rightly uh is
saying it's a Russian May uh missile
whether this is a Russian missile which
directly so to speak travel to Poland
whether it's a Russian missile which was
uh you know diverted it's caused by
acquaintance or even if it was a
Ukrainian elephants missile which was
trying to defend of course Ukraine
against this attack which trade and
unfortunately killed the Polish citizens
it is still the case that this type of
situation would not arise if it was if
it was not for The Reckless barbaric war
that Russia is waging every day you know
I mean more than half I believe in
happiness of Kiev have been without
electricity and heating throughout the
night this is the reality and you know
NATO has to be involved because this is
an extremely serious situation the one
that you know uh both Poland and NATO
such has warned Russia against and you
know we would not be even discussing
this sort of issue if Russia stopped the
war stopped the missile attacks so this
is really the the focus that we should
take and as it happens apart from the
NATO meeting which should start indeed
in an hour and two hours time uh there
is also a new crane defense uh support
to Ukraine coordinating meeting which
we'll discuss further support to Ukraine
including let's hope more uh defense
systems more uh type of equipment which
will help Ukraine to defend itself but
also uh will actually make other
countries safer because you know this
situation is in terrible it's um you
know I mean for British U.S imagine if
there was a missile uh which suddenly
hit a part of Cornwell or you know
Aberdeen et cetera I mean this this
cannot go on but the clue uh the key to
this lies in Russia stopping it and it
seems at the moment the best way to stop
it is to ensure that Ukraine achieves a
victory on the battlefield because it is
winning this war
yeah I suppose the most pressing
question overnight though is is what's
happened uh on polish soil triggering
articles four and five of the NATO
agreement in your opinion
I think we went far away from Article
Five because you know that would involve
you know premeditated consistent attack
the Polish president last night said
that you know there are all the signs
that this was and and you know hopefully
isolated incident but nevertheless it is
serious because you know a security of
one Ally is a security uh of others too
and you know uh
Holland is is actually being very uh
diligent in terms of not uh raising the
stakes not going for any kind of you
know escalation but wants to get to the
bottom of it they are actually also NATO
and American specifically experts which
which are part of investigation and uh
all the I would say proper if you like
political and security policy procedures
are being followed because nobody is
interested in escalation but at the same
time put yourself in the situation of uh
of the people uh living in Poland and
frankly other countries like the Baltic
states who are very close to this front
line not to mention the Ukrainian
themselves this cannot go on Russia
cannot be threatening and causing this
type of habit and and Factor directly or
indirectly killing people in Europe
today so uh there have to be even more
efficient ways to improve our security
but also to prevent Russia to make it
impossible for Russia to uh to continue
and frankly any statements emanating
from Russia at this stage should be
treated with uh you know with
you know more than a caution because we
know for a fact that Russia has been
engaged in this information lying at the
highest level for a very long time
you're referring of course there to the
former Russian president Medvedev who's
saying that we're edging ever closer to
another world war you talked about the
situation in Poland and other countries
that are bordering
um the bordering Russia what more can be
done to keep the people of those
countries safe
well I think again I've already alluded
to this I mean we the Paradox is this
that although Ukraine is not a member of
data if you ask a lot of people that
would say it should be but it's not but
the fact though it is the country that
is by defending itself very heroically
but also very uh you know
effectively it is actually uh you know
doing probably the most to uh to
guarantee to help with the security of
the rest of Europe
and we still have some kind of an
ongoing debate uh you know in which some
countries uh UK by the way is is an
exemplary Ally because it has been
extremely supportive of Ukraine in a
variety of ways but also you know a
stone channel for Poland and there are
many others but then there's still some
reluctance to for instance provide uh
the necessary additional uh you know
equipment to Ukraine as far as countries
like Poland which is a frontier State
well I think uh perhaps um you know uh
additional stationing of fighter planes
from other NATO countries additional
elements of the of the air defense
equipment would be an order and perhaps
there's also a time to revisit the issue
of at least thinking about a possible uh
you know
you know essentialization of some kind
of a no-fly zone because again I stress
you know this cannot happen this this
should not be repeated and Russia has to
be uh you know has to be made to
understand that this is reckless and you
know uh while nobody wants of course any
escalation uh but at the same time you
know uh this type of behavior because
again uh it is Russian actions which
lead to this uh will not be tolerated
this is the message which should go out
from all the capitals of of Europe and
uh and North America and Beyond
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for taking the time this morning
thank you
these are live images
from uh just inside Poland on the border
there about five miles inside from
Ukraine
um it would appear that a rogue missile
originally had been thought potentially
it was had been fired by the Russians
that now appears that potentially it was
a Ukrainian missile that had been
launched to try to stop a barrage of
missiles fired from Russia um aimed at
Kiev and other major cities in Ukraine
overnight two people sadly have lost
their lives we'll get more information
on this and we are expecting a statement
from our own prime minister at the G20
Summit in Bali that in around about
excuse me about about half an hour's
time we'll bring that to you live here
on Sky
meantime let's take you to the us that
are a lot to dissuade Donald Trump from
attempting another run at the White
House a bit of Investigation into his
involvement with the 2021 Capital riots
poor results in last week's midterms for
the candidates that he backed and a
republican rival who is fast becoming
the party favorite all of that
he still decided that he was going to
run here's our report
[Music]
to an Anthem of Revolution and into a
sea of his most loyal supporters please
welcome the next president and first
lady of the United States of America the
former president with his pitch to be
the next one America's comeback starts
right now
for over an hour he spoke it was a
vision of his America against today's
America his achievements against Biden's
challenges
China Russia Iran and North Korea were
in check
and respected they respected the United
States and quite honestly they respected
me he dismissed the many legal
investigations against him and I'm a
victim I will tell you and the fact that
his candidates were so often not the
chosen ones in last week's midterms well
that's fake news he said and then the
moment they'd been waiting for in order
to make America great and glorious again
I am tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the foot soldiers of the trumpism
movement
only the most loyal here of course but
this does stretch across the country and
it cuts into society
so many times the Republican Party
establishment has tried to cut Trump
loose after the January the sixth
Insurrection and many trumpian moments
in between they try and they try but
they just can't let him go because they
know that this Remains the reality
denying force behind the party he
deserves another shot the first the
second election was rigged from him
um they really believe that of course I
believe it have you seen all of the
fraud out of Arizona look what happened
right now man this is tremendous maybe
we can correct all the things that
that Joe Biden's done wrong now we had
to do it once now we're going to get to
do it again
he can't simply be switched off or
directed Elsewhere for as long as they
stand by the man in the palace behind
them he'll continue to be a force Mark
Stone Sky News at Mar-A-Lago in Florida
[Music]
Mark is with us now it was a Willy Wonky
Willy won't he was always going to run
wasn't he Mark good morning
okay yeah he was you know I was
reflecting on that a few hours ago as I
was watching his speech because just
last week that there were lots of us
myself including what included wondering
how he would frame today because
remember the the candidates he endorsed
in the midterm elections many of them
did not win yeah some of them did win
some of them only lost by a fraction but
a lot of them did lose and so how would
he frame this um this long uh trailed
announcement that he will run again in
2024 remember he's a guy who does not
like to lose well he believes he can win
I have to say I felt I think others
certainly on social media have been have
been saying the same including his
Deputy press secretary from his last run
as president that it didn't he felt a
bit it sounded a bit lackluster he
didn't seem to have quite the energy you
might expect but nevertheless the room
the Ballroom in that um that Palace that
Resort behind me was full of the Great
in the good of the make America great
again movement the Maga movement outside
here the most loyal of his fans were
here I think we're in for the mother of
all battles now within the Republican
party because remember as I said time
and again the the uh the establishment
of the party the Old Guard have tried to
peel themselves away from Trump because
they see the difficulties with the Trump
presidency they see the problems with
the last one but they're always drawn
back to him because trumpism has an
enduring power we've seen it across the
country we'll see the mother of all
battles because there are others waiting
in the wings there will be a home turf
battle here in Florida because Rhonda
Sanchez the the Republican governor of
Florida he's a dead cert to run as well
for president he was um his career was
made by Trump the two men are now
um well out and out enemies I think you
could probably say um it's going to be
Ron versus Don that's just one of the
two uh rivalries that we will see in the
Republican party is it probably eats
itself apart over the next two years
Donald Trump though will he's first out
of the blocks he's running
for no thanks very much indeed mark
thank you joined Now by Brian Lanza Mr
Trump's former deputy communications
director hello to you Mr Lanza thanks
for joining us just looking at what
Ivanka Trump
um has been saying confirming uh that uh
she and her husband Jared Kushner no
intention of public supporting Donald
Trump's Run for the White House
um it's an uphill challenge for him
isn't it
absolutely I mean thank you for having
me first of all it's certainly an uphill
battle for for the former president and
I would put him at this particular point
the underdog but I also State he loves
being the underdog and uh he does really
well when he's the underdog so this is
the one he's actually the most dangerous
uh politically incense that uh he's he's
willing to take more risks than the
average politician when he's an underdog
so it's going to be it's going to be an
interesting two years
it was hugely important to him having
his family by his side when he was
actually in the White House how will he
cope during the campaign not having
people like his trusty son-in-law and
his daughter there
he's going to have other family there I
think Don Jr his namesake he's going to
be involved in the campaign so he'll be
there he'll be actively involved so I
mean you know it's just the way it goes
some families involved some's not uh but
uh certainly uh you know Don Jr Kimberly
in some parts of the family are going to
be involved in the journey new vanco and
you just have have other priorities
right now yeah it certainly seems that
way what do you make of his timing I
mean it wasn't a great week last week
with the results of the midterms
no listen I think he was uh the
president was committed to this to this
gate he said it before the election that
he's going to be making a major
announcement done November 15th and
regardless of what was going to happen
with with the midterm elections and he
was stuck to the state it probably
wasn't the best State uh to do to do a
presidential launch but uh you know for
him you know he made the date and he
sticks by it because if he would have
changed it it would have been viewed as
humiliating or as weak and that's
something that the president uh doesn't
like to go down that route
interesting that he was making his
announcement in
um in Florida which of course is home
for Ronda Santos or Rhonda sanctimonious
as he calls him
um do you think it's going to be a fight
between the two of them
no listen I think Ron has a long way to
go I mean you know I would say this here
in the United States you know run
success as a governor is probably you
know I would I would use this you would
equate to being a you know a success at
the college level but success at the
presidential level is more of the
professional level of politics and Ron
hasn't succeeded at that level yet so
he's he's moving up a class and we'll
see how he does there's other gonna
there's gonna be other candidates in the
field who've who've played at that
presidential level before Chris Christie
and others and and uh Ron has some you
know he he starts to prove himself that
he's at the presidential level and he
hasn't done that yet
talk to us about midterm results is it a
little bit like our by-elections where
people tend to vote as a sort of protest
vote but then actually when it comes to
the main election the general election
for US presidential election for you
they may potentially vote a different
way
yeah you know it's it's the midterm is
oftentimes the the first report card
voters get to give an increment
president and uh you know and Joe Biden
had a good midterm uh the key is is two
years you know the re-election November
2024 is is two years away it's a very
long way uh in respect to politics and a
lot can happen the economy can get worse
we could end up in World War III and the
voters aren't satisfied you know how Joe
Biden sort of got us into World War III
I mean two years is a very very long
time away you know Joe Biden is a
front-runner you know Trump's the
underdog and but uh in those times so
much can happen
do you think as things stand that Trump
can win the nomination and then go on to
beat Biden
yeah I'd say right now Trump's certainly
going to win the nomination he's a
front-runner he's a force in the
Republican party I think the Joe Biden
fight in the November of 2024 becomes an
epic battle and I think it's too early
to tell in my view that if president
Trump can win or if Joe Biden to lose
like I said there's there's just too
many issues uh that can change the
dynamic in American politics between now
and 2024 but uh it's it's certainly uh
it's setting this stuff up to be a
heavyweight fight here
okay thanks very much Cindy for joining
us and for staying up specially thank
you
first thank you
World Cup starts in Qatar on Sunday and
videos are already being shared showing
fans swarming the streets of Doha
but it's not all that it seems Tick Tock
Channel Qatari living share the videos
but now there are questions of the
authenticity of the fans with almost
identical videos showing similar crowds
wearing different team kits the Gulf
State has been accused of paying fake
fans to sing and dance in choreographed
events including Renditions of it's
coming home from England fans surely
they should know it's sweet Caroline
some of the fans tell reporters they
love the England team while admitting
there had not been to England before
England holding their first training
session in Qatar today ahead of their
opening World Cup match against Iran on
Monday the manager of Gareth Southgate
says his side are looking forward to
testing their ability on the world stage
let's get more Sherry Ali is standing by
for us indoor
um lots to talk about not least the fact
that the England team say they are or
certainly the captain is going to wear
his one world armband
yeah and the England team arrived on a
Verge Atlantic especially chartered
plane uh by the fa last night which was
called rainbow and was given the
registration letters PRD which is short
for Pride so the England team not
clearly afraid to make a statement uh in
support of LGBT rights they're doing so
before they even took off uh to get here
but they landed late yesterday evening
they're in the hotel now south of here
they will hold their first training
session today and the Welsh team as well
playing their first World Cup since 1958
well they landed in the middle
um middle of the night I suspect they're
pretty tired they're in a hotel really
very close to where we are here just
down the coast from here and they're not
expected to hold a training session
today in quite the same way just because
of the late arrival both teams will get
their campaigns underway a week from
today uh next Monday they begin their
World Cup bid in Earnest Harry Kane has
said that he believes England and can
win the World Cup he says that he's not
afraid of making that bold statement
they are one of the bookies favorite
England despite having a pretty shaky
last few months in the run-up to it but
they've got a pretty good pedigree of
championship history behind them in
recent years of course they reached the
final of the European championships just
last year and so this is a group of
players in particular who will hope that
they can go all the way but England and
Wales will be up against each other
they're in the same group so the
national rivalries will spill out over
here in the Middle East as well
okay thanks so much indeed Ali thank you
and at quarter 10 joined by the England
lioness Demi Stokes to talk through her
views of this year's host nation
um meantime
just want to bring you a statement from
Jeremy Hunt who is of course our
Chancellor or Finance Minister as he's
called elsewhere around the world he
said
um that tough but necessary decisions
required to tackle Rising prices
um when he makes his Autumn statement
tomorrow our duty to help the bank of
England in their mission to return
inflation to Target by acting
responsibly with the nation's finances
that requires listen to this some tough
but necessary decisions on tax and
spending to help balance the books um
Andrew's sentence used to work with the
bank of England he's with us now
monetary policy committee to be precise
what does he mean do you think by
um top but necessary decisions on tax
and spending
well I think the government's going to
be looking to increase spending by less
than was previously planned
and they uh May well announce some tax
increases but I think they need to be
careful about this because the main
instrument that we have uh to curb
inflation is the interest rate and
that's with the bank of England the bank
of England is going to have to raise
interest rates further
um Jeremy Hunt needs to make sure that
he's not tightening too much
with his public spending and tax
announcements when he makes them
tomorrow
okay 11.1 percent though that is
alarming
um 41 year high yes it's a very high
rate of inflation it's five and a half
times the two percent Target that the
bank is Meant to hit
um now the increase uh this month
um is mainly driven by food and energy
prices the rise from 10.1 to 11.1 if you
take those out
inflation is still very high it will be
6.5 without food and energy price
inflation and I think that's going to be
the big concern for the bank of England
that is not just to do with food and
energy prices it's not just to do with
the war in Ukraine there's more
generalized problem with inflation in
the economy for example Furniture prices
going up by about 10 restaurants and
hotels uh components in the Consumer
Price Index going up by about 10
so there's a more generalized problem of
inflation which the bank of England
needs to get on top of right if england
had been predicting 13 though hadn't
they in some instances although we're
hearing from Paul at the top of the show
when these figures first dropped and he
was suggesting that this is probably as
high as it's going to go
well the bank of England forecast uh
that in the last three months of this
year
um and October which we've just had the
figures for is one of those months uh
inflation is going to average about 10.9
so just below 11 now it's gone above 11
but I would be wary about saying this is
as bad as it gets
um because the bank's forecast doesn't
really suggest that inflation is going
to come down
um significantly until the middle of
next year so I think we're in for a few
more shocks perhaps on the inflation
front over the winter and where does
that leave our viewers at home who are
watching this and thinking 11.1 I can
never remember it being that high
no well um it is hard to remember
because it wasn't that High
um it hasn't been that high since the
early 1980s
there may be some people who are saying
I wasn't even born then and some people
have just got on the housing ladder and
are going to see their interest rates go
up quite significantly they're going to
be quite concerned there is obviously
going to be a squeeze on the economy
um because of higher interest rates and
that's where why Jeremy Hunt needs to be
careful of not making that squeeze too
intense in the short-term options does
he have well I think his options are
to ask departments to Reign back on
public spending but there's some very
big areas of public spending that the
government really can't economize on
like health and education I mean the
government spends money on things
because they're of benefit to us and
therefore it's going to be in my view a
long haul in terms of getting public
finances properly under control
rather than just something that he's
going to need to do for a year or two
there needs to be a long-term plan
that's announced tomorrow and he needs
to take account of the fact that if he
squeezes too hard if he goes too hard in
cutting spending or raising taxes he may
actually make the problem of the economy
worse
perhaps not as bad as the disastrous
coupling of truss and quoting and their
mini budget at the end of September
we've been told recently that that's
cost 30 odd billion pounds to the UK
economy where does that money go
well I think some of it is to do with
higher interest uh payments that the
government has to make
some of it is a range of other things
that were caused by all the volatility
um that that budget Unleashed
um but I think that highlights the fact
that that
um that that budget went in the opposite
direction it was it was cutting taxes it
was um spending extra money
um
if you do too big a Lurch with
government spending and tax then you can
create unpredictable economic
consequences so Jeremy Hunt's got a bit
of a balancing act to do
to do enough to show that he's getting
public finances under control
but not to destabilize the economy by
tightening too much in the short term
the 11.1 percent inflation the highest
in 41 years as you said can that be good
news for anybody
um I don't think inflation is good news
um
it's a there's a good reason why we have
Bank of England tasked with trying to
keep inflation uh at around about two
percent which is sufficiently low that
nobody would really notice it
um I was thinking particularly about
Savers interest rates going up as a
result of inflation and well it should
be Savers well there is some
um upside from higher interest rates for
people who are trying to save
um and want to rely on interest income
and actually to some extent we're
redressing the balance from a long
period where interest rates uh were too
low in my opinion
and where
um Savers therefore were disadvantaged
now borrowers are going to to experience
increased costs but as you say Savers
are likely to benefit uh from from
higher interest rates but
the question is really getting the right
level of interest rates for the economy
and the priority at the moment for the
bank of England is going to be to raise
interest rates to a level where it
actually begins to control inflation and
bring it down let's see what happens
after tomorrow's Autumn statement it's
good to talk to you Mr sentence thanks
for coming in to see us thanks
return to Ukraine should we earlier in
the program I spoke uh to a former
polish Diplomat and NATO official he
said that Russia can't be allowed to
cause this much this much destruction
this cannot go on Russia cannot be
threatening and causing this type of
havoc and Factor directly or indirectly
killing people in Europe today so uh
there have to be even more efficient
ways to improve our security but also to
prevent Russia to uh make it impossible
for Russia to uh to continue
tomorrow is here for us um obviously
NATO we need to talk about that and
what's happening with inflation figures
indeed you heard Andrew's sentence there
formerly the bank of England this is we
are not at the worst Point yet I
remember in recent weeks ministers were
desperately hoping that in that
inflation might fall a bit from the uh
10 level of last month because of the
energy price guarantee and because
wholesale gas prices were falling that
has not happened it is now higher than
ever higher than at any point since the
Falklands War and there is really for
Jeremy Hunt as he stands up to do his
Autumn statement tomorrow very little
Prospect of any relief from the cost of
living crisis that people are
experiencing these high energy prices
that people are experiencing are feeding
into higher food prices in the shops and
yet when public sector unions go to the
government saying can we have a pay rise
the answer is if we give you a much
higher pay rise that will just fuel
further inflation so the pressure is
really on the government to try and
bring this under control and I'm sure
that's what we're going to hear from the
chancellor tomorrow
thanks filled NASA's Artemis rocket
launched with the aim to send humans
back to the lunar surface for the first
time in 50 years Artemis who was I think
I'm right in saying the Greek goddess of
hunting
and the twin sister of Apollo
I think so I was hoping somebody might
tell me dad might tell me and Darren
might tell me in the gallery but they
haven't so we'll move on and talk about
the health secretary Steve Barkley um
not directly addressing concerns
regarding staff pay at today's annual
NHS providers conference Source telling
Sky News uh that the health secretary
will refer any decision on staff pay to
the pay review body let's talk about it
in more detail uh should we and joining
us is Andy Prendergast GMP GMB National
secretary how are you fine thank you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning what do you think where are
we as far as the new health secretary is
concerned you've had a few to deal with
um yeah well it's been a bit of a
revolving door over the last decade ever
since Jeremy Hunt left and unfortunately
left the NHS in a far worse State and he
found it we dealt with numerous Health
secretaries we believe the NHS is now in
crisis we're seeing strike ballots from
multiple unions right across the service
and quite frankly we need to see a
significant cash injection to deal with
long-standing Recruitment and Retention
issues that ultimately are affecting
patient care especially the health
secretary you know the education
secretary who was a health Minister
Jillian Keegan and she told me that the
starting pay for nurses was 34 000
pounds is that right
um it's roughly that um well to be
honest it is a lot of money well it's
not a huge amount of money when you
consider the amount of training nurses
need to do
um and you know nursing is an
exceptionally responsible job but NHS
pay doesn't just cover nurses it covers
everyone from Porters to paramedics to
nurses to administrators and many of
those people are on Far lower rates but
even with nursing the reality is we're
dealing with roughly a 10 Gap in a
number of nurses we need and you know
normally simple capitalism is about if
you can't recruit on the amount you're
offering you have to up the offer now
our members are exhausted they're
working under far from ideal
circumstances and conditions and what
they're seeing is the Health Service
basically withering away around them and
they want to see a Health Service that
they're proud of and what we've seen
instead is 12 years of Decline and it
has to stop so somewhere but 34 000
pounds as a starting salary is a good
salary so a lot of people will be saying
please don't go on strike because I've
been waiting however long I've been
waiting for my routine appointment and I
can't have it and the numbers are
something like 7 million now aren't they
well they are seven million and that
seven million is seven million that's a
number that has basically increased to
that level Under 12 years of
conservative Rule and a covered pandemic
well it wasn't there was a covert
pandemic but the fact is waiting lists
were far higher going into the pandemic
than they were a decade before
um you know we're a general Union in a
GMB we're seeing now members being fired
while they're waiting for treatment the
cost to the state is astronomical you
know we're having to pay benefits for
people who should be getting operations
and quite frankly our members in the NHS
are seeing a service getting worse and
worse and they're saying this has to
change and we as a society have a choice
we either fund it properly we either
fund the people who do the job or we
continue to see it wither away will you
bite I'm just going to grab some water
will you abide by the pay review body
um well the pay review body has offered
five percent that's been soundly
rejected we don't accept that the the
pay review bodies findings the pay
review body has seen in HS pay with her
over the last decade we've not seen
inflation pay Rises for a long time and
we're seeing that in a huge number of
vacancies on Wards up and down the
country so quite frankly unless the pay
review body is willing to put a pay
increase that will at least maintain
level current levels of earnings which
will be over 12 and a half percent using
RPI then quite frankly we are going to
see strikes what is the point of a peer
review body if you don't divide by it
well to be honest we've never signed up
to the pay review buddy
well I mean the pay review body
um you know firstly the recommendations
are not always accepted and Jeremy Hunt
he ignored the recommendations when it
recommended one percent a number of
years ago and he was criticized he was
criticized or rightly criticized but the
pay-review body has led to NHS staff pay
uh withering is worth about 10 less now
than it was a decade ago it's continued
to oversee a decline in the NHS it's
continuing to mean that people aren't
joining the service and quite frankly
unless this is addressed more and more
working people are going to see their
operations delayed they're going to see
problems getting the treatment that
they've been paying for with tax their
entire lives and I think the British
public fundamentally deserve better but
if we've got an economic crisis
um we've just seen what inflation is
doing where um if we're not already in
recession we're on on the edge of
recession
um the I'm guessing chancellor who was a
previously Health secretary as you said
would say I can't afford to give you the
sort of money you're asking for well
this is a choice you know and ultimately
when you look at a taxation system in
Britain you can raise huge amounts of
money without normal working people
having to pay a penny more you can look
at higher rate tax levels you can look
at rates of um you know the rates are
paid on dividends that are significantly
lower than wages you can look at
decisions that are made multiple times
to delay things like stamp Duty you can
look at tax loot polls non-dom status
there are ways of raising money and what
you have to remember with the NHS we
built the NHS in the late 1940s when as
a country the debt had never been higher
when we were absolutely broke but we
managed to build something that
supported British people through life
and death ever since and what we're
saying is this Choice needs to be made
and it needs to be made quickly
significantly more people now than there
were then and significantly more elderly
people now there are but at the same
point we're a significantly richer
country and when you you have a
significantly richer country I think
normal people have to ask a question as
to why they're expected to accept a
second-class service we're out of time
but just to check with you do you think
that other NHS workers will be joining
nurses to go on strike yes thank you for
joining us on the program thanks a lot